millions of Pokemon goat trainers around
the world are exploring their
communities in a quest to catch them all
the app doesn't have very much of an
in-game tutorial system so we've
compiled a list of the most essential
things you should know before setting
forth in search of a dragon air or mu2 I
choose You Pikachu want to be just like
Ash and get Pikachu or starter Pokemon
it takes a little bit of work but
Professor willow presents you with a
Bulbasaur squirtle and Charmander on
your map simply walk away from them once
you get out of range the three critters
will appear again next to you repeat the
process walking away from them four
times the next time they appear a
Pikachu will also be there waiting for
you and the circle is complete sort your
Pokemon tired of scrolling through your
bag in search of that Clefairy you know
you caught yesterday take advantage of
the in-game sorting options on the
Pokemon view interface tap the icon at
the bottom right of the screen you'll be
given numerous sorting options to choose
from including name time caught combat
power hit points pokedex number and
other information pokemon tracking
pokemon that show up in the nearby list
won't come closer to you if you use an
incense or lure module since those are
determined randomly and don't require
movement for them to spawn the number of
footprints below a Pokemon in the list
indicates their distance and each
footprint represents approximately 30 to
50 meters you can tap on the list to
open a grid and use it to navigate tap
on your target in the list and then
start walking as you get closer the
targeted critter will move up and to the
left of the list if you're walking in
the wrong direction the Pokemon will
move down and to the right on the grid
when it reaches the top left position on
the grid it will be the closest Pokemon
- you keep homing in and the footprints
will drop to 2 then 1 and then none when
you're right next to it
great throws catching a Pokemon isn't as
simple as just chucking a pokeball that
an animal's head when you target a
creature holding your finger down in the
pokeball will generate a shrinking
target ring the ring colors indicate how
difficult each creature is to catch
Green is easy
yellow is average orange difficult and
red is very hard
toss your pokeball through the colored
circle as it shrinks accuracy Nets
additional X
and a higher catch chance you can spin
your pokeball until it sparkles right
before you toss it and get a curveball
XP bonus super balls and ultra balls
make catching pokémon with orange and
red targeting circles easier Pokemon can
be bribed with raspberries which also
increases your chances but only for one
throw fighting gym battles just like
catching pokémon battling with them is
more complicated than it seems
you're creatures all have to attack
moves a primary move and a special one
that must charge up when fighting at a
gym
tap your Pokemon to use their primary
move and keep an eye on the special move
bar located below your pokemons name
when the special meter is full hold down
your finger on your Pokemon to unleash
their special move don't forget you can
also swipe left or right to dodge
incoming attacks keep these tips in mind
and your next fight should be super
effective diversity is key before you go
charging into an enemy gym with six
Wimpy pidgeys remember that Pokemon
types are essentially a more complex
version of rock-paper-scissors grass
beats water water beats fire fire beats
grass and so on so you should build a
diverse team that's best suited to fight
the Pokemon defending the gym when you
initiate a gym battle you'll be shown
your team of six at the bottom of your
screen tap any Pokemon to switch them
out with another from your collection
then start the battle when you're ready
gym takeovers if you win a battle at an
enemy gym you may be surprised when the
enemy team retains possession of it
that's because gym ownership is based on
overall team prestige you may have to
battle the gym successfully multiple
times in a row to lower the gyms
prestige to zero bring friends along to
make the takeover process faster once it
hits zero the gym will become neutral
and you can install one of your own
pokemon to defend it gym leaders are
determined by which pokemon at that gym
leads and combat points or CP for every
gym you lead or support you'll get a
daily package filled with polka coins
for use in the online shop train your
pokémon gyms also have several levels of
their own based on their battle prestige
the higher level the gym is the more
people on your team can put pokemon in
the gym the more Pokemon there are in a
gym the harder it is for challengers to
initiate a takeover training your
Pokemon is simple just visit a gym
that's already controlled by your team
once there you can train by battling
against your own team's pokemon defeat
all of them and your gyms prestige will
go up making it more difficult to be
defeated by another team and also
opening new slots for more defenders to
be added
smart evolutions hold on to your highest
CPD Pokemon and transfer lower-level
duplicates to Professor Willow in
exchange for candy
don't waste your candy evolving a
Pokemon if it has a low CP bar while
it'll still get a relative boost in
power it will be in the exact same
position on the CP Ark in its evolved
form and cost you more candy and start
us to power up aim to evolve Pokemon
that are already strong in CP or power
them up first before evolving if a
Pokemon CP arc is completely full that
means you cannot power them up any
further due to your trainers level level
up your trainer first and then that
pokemon will have space to be powered up
again battery saver mode and battery
packs here's a tip for trainers in the
real world not the digital one the game
and the GPS tracking it can drain your
phone's battery life quickly
additionally you can leave the app open
to get notifications of nearby Pokemon
to get the most gametime out of your
device close your other apps and turn on
your phone's battery saver option you
should also invest in a couple of
portable power banks to charge your
phone only buy ones that pack at least
10,000 milliamp hours of charge and you
should be able to stay in business
catching pokémon for several hours treat
just don't blame us if you use up all
your data playing Pokemon go thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what Pokemon go tips you
think are super effective